[applause]
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
I'm
Carla Hayden, and I'll truly
delighted
to have you here.  You may clap
right now, again.
[applause]
SPEAKER: I have to take this
opportunity to welcome those in
the home towns of our national
student poets who are watching
the live stream of this event.
Thank you to our live stream
partners
and I feel like I should wave,
Cabble County Public Library in
West
Virginia and Henley Research
Library in Birmingham, Alabama.
Fletcher Free Library in
Burlington, Vermont.
The Mason Main Library and Red
Mountain Library in Mesa,
Arizona and
Las Vegas Springs Preserve
Academy in Las Vegas, Nevada.
I have to also tell you that
I was
very pleased and honored to hold
a pinning ceremony for these
talented young poets in my
office area, just less than an
hour ago.  And it's the second
time that we've been able to
have that honor and I have
to say, it's one of the
highlights of the year.  We also
have two poets from the previous
year, who are with us today.
We're delighted to see them as
well.
Now...
at the pinning, and the pinning,
really, you have to see the
beautiful pins, at the pinning,
I was joined by
Kit Matthew, Director of the
Institute and Museum of Library
Services.  Kit.
[applause]
SPEAKER: Virginia Macanu for the
Alliance of Young Artists and
Writers.  You'll hear from them
in a minute, but let me say how
much I appreciate their
stewardship of the poets program
and commitment to our next
generation of poets.
Now...
you'll also hear from two very
special guests this afternoon.
Noted columnist Mr. David
brooks.
[applause]
SPEAKER: And singer/song writer,
Valerie June.
[applause]
powerful voices, both of our
special guests have
found inspiration at the Library
of Congress, Mr. Brooks has
written about the power of the
Thomas Jefferson building,
across the street.
It was there that Valerie June
immersed herself in the
recordings.
Darius, Daniel, Alexandra,
Heather,
Laurel, Jenson and Arianna, I
hope you
are equally-inspired by
beginning your national student
poet term here at the Library of
Congress, we are very proud
that you, and I'm telling you
from previous poets, will always
have that connection to us.
As I told you at the pinning and
you
presented me with
autograph copies and you all
will be jealous.  Don't forget
us as you become famous.  You
are famous now.
Now, there's another remarkable
poet, connected to the library
who is excited to be part of
this day.
And right now, she's flying back
from
Alaska, where she kicked off her
second
term project, American
Conversations,
Celebrating Poetry in Rural
Communities.  Before she left,
she recorded a special message
for you.
He's trying to get sound and I
want it noted that I'm not doing
this.  It makes me feel good
when someone else has these
technology issues.
I'm so tempted to try to help.
There was opening music.
It's Tracy Smith, the poet
laureate and she's in her second
year and she
wanted to emphasize using poetry
in specifically, rural
communities.
So... what we're going to
do...
and I wish I had like one iota
of her talent because...
I could actually read some of
her poetry.  And tell you...
so, you see her and she wanted
to do this...
and we will make sure this is
available shortly.
Because, I had the opportunity
to talk
to Tracy and asked her to record
this.  Because...
she believes in the healing
power of poetry.  And...
when she was selected as poet
laureate, it was one of my first
opportunities to be involved
with the program.
She said she wanted to go to
communities that had needed
other ways to talk about
difficult and challenging
issues.
And so...
in rural areas, Native-American
communities --
[applause]
SPEAKER: I'm sorry I'm not there
with you tonight, I'm actually
in Alaska, talking poetry with
new friends, but I'm excited to
join you tomorrow and celebrate
your accomplishments.
SPEAKER: We wanted sound -- and
we've got it, so... we'll make
sure though, that you get to see
all of her message, because...
basically, that's what she's
hoping
that you, young poets will
realize, that your words and
your way with words have a way
of reaching out to others that
might not have their own way of
expressing things.  And that's
what she wanted to wish for you.
Because she's found that in her
career.
And she's taking it in another
year, to communities throughout
this country, that need the
healing power of words.
So... I hope you will enjoy
meeting her tomorrow, her flight
is on schedule.  She will be
here, and now I'm going to bring
up Kit to continue the program.
[applause]
SPEAKER: That video will be a
treat.
Thank you, I'm former member of
the National Museum and Library
Services Board.  We welcome you
to D.C. We always enjoy working
with our colleagues at the
library of Congress on the
National Book Festival, coming
up this weekend.  I hope many of
you will partake of that.  I'm
delighted to be with you all
today to celebrate this 2018
class of the National Student
Poets Program.  We are extremely
proud to have partnered with the
alliance for young artists and
writers to establish the
program which shares exemplary
work from
teen poets like we honored today
with a national audience.
IMLS supports libraries and
museums, large and small, across
the country as
they enhance many forms of
literacy and artistic
expression, including this
poetry program.  Writing and
libraries are always
intertwined.  I was reminded of
this last week when up in Maine.
I've been telling my Maine
friends about upcoming
activities at IMLS.  I can't
turn off my brain about
libraries and museums, including
this poetry celebration.
The next day, my friend was
driving
me on one of those endless
winding Maine roads, my friend
suddenly turned the Jeep off the
road through a battered chain
link fence into a small
cemetery.
The grass was dry, scuffy, and
there were very few graveside
decorations.  It seemed
utilitarian and in fact,
ignored.
At the very back edge of the
cemetery with a very nondescript
plot under a tree.
Elwyn Brooks White.
Various votives, rocks,
sculptures, painted notes were
perched on the headstone.
MVP White
-- many of White's books were
donated to a library in Maine.
EB White left an inscription.
In a letter addressed to
children in
Michigan, congratulating them
upon their
newly opened public library, EB
White wrote:  Books hold many of
the secrets of the world, books
are people, people
who have managed to stay alive
by hiding between the covers of
a book.
And we can say the same of
poetry, as White did of books.
Poetry holds many of the secrets
of
the world and people stay alive
within and through poetry.
Many libraries and museums
across our nation are critical
platforms for community
expression and advancing
literacy and learning for all
Americans.
And the National Student Poets
Program leverages the shared
community spaces to
create new perspectives, connect
us across generations and spark
critical and essential
conversations.
This year's five exceptional
student writers, Darius, Daniel,
Alexandra, Heather and Arianna
were selected by
some of our nation's finest
literary voices and leaders in
education and they rose to the
top of more than 300 national
medalists.  That's a fete.
In the scholastic art and
writing awards.
They will receive academic
awards, opportunities to
showcase their work in
libraries, museums, schools and
at festivals and events across
America.
And they'll serve as regional,
literary ambassadors for the
coming year.
Each student poet from this
year's
class is charged with designing
a special community service
project which may include
readings, workshops, webinars,
classroom visits, interviews and
conversations with established
poets.
In previous years, they've
focused outreach on military
families, Alzheimer's patients,
English as second language
students, homeless, youth and
Native-American students.
I look forward to hearing how
each of you will reach out to
others.  This is just the
beginning.  Whether reading EB
White or participating in a
poetry slam, I truly believe
anyone can own the power of
poetry and have a voice.  Our
phone winning poets are
ambassadors for poetry's power
to inspire curiosity, learning,
confidence and connections.  I
want to congratulate you on your
accomplishments, and we look
forward to your continued
service throughout the next
year.  Thank you.
[applause]
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Welcome... I'm Virginia
McNearney.
I'm the Executive Director of
The
Alliance for Artists and
Writers.
We are so honored to be
partnered with IMLS in
presenting this wonderful
program to poets and writers
across the country.
I want to thank the Library of
Congress for hosting us at this
event.  We have special guests
here in the audience.  I'd be
remiss if I didn't start by
thanking and honoring Olivia
Morgan, who is the head -- who
started the program.  Thank you,
Olivia, so glad you're here.
[applause]
SPEAKER: The inspiration behind
the programs.  I also want to
welcome Dr.
Lucie Ann
Milkowitz.
She's holds the Chair in
Astrobiology at the Library of
Congress.  She included on her
post-doc fellowship application
to Princeton, the scholastic
award for painting she won in
10th grade.  It gave her the
idea she could be what she
wanted to be.
I also want to acknowledge and
thank my friends from the poetry
coalition
under the leadership of Jen Ba
nka.  It's great of you to
launch these young poets in
their year of service.
These fine poets became eligible
to
be appointed as national student
poets, because they first
received national
awards through the Scholastic
Art And Writing Awards.  Started
in 1923, about the time the word
teenager first appeared in the
dictionary.  Our mission and
purpose is to encourage creative
young people.
We have the privilege of
launching these creative young
people onto their year of
service and I wish all of you
could get to see some of them at
work, as I do.
Last year, I went on tour in
Idaho,
with Kim Sale Houston who worked
in a number of different
settings.
She did a poetry workshop for
Docents at Boise Art Museum.
And spent the day at Boise High
School where students wrote
poems about their homes.
When it came time to share, one
of the
15-year-old students started
reading "I remember my first
home...
" and went on to describe seven
more homes and details about the
light, the step families that
had come and gone.
A stunning moment, a pause, the
class did this...
a lot of this in the Scholastic
Art and Writing Awards and they
moved on.  I reflected on that
student quite a bit.
She so aptly described how
poetry shortcuts the expression
of complex emotions and ideas
and how powerful it
is, it has the power to connect
us, to
explain, to provoke, to express,
to explore.  Very complicated
being a teenager these days.
It always has been, but
especially now.  What better
pastime could they possibly grab
onto than poetry and helping
guide them through the teenage
years?
These teen poets are
particularly well-suited to
advocate.  They're young enough
to be relatable to young kids
and mature enough for adults to
take them seriously.
The 2018 Class of National
Student Poets joins a legacy of
young writers
who feel poetry in their bones
and... their voices are strong
and unique and they will enter
their year of service, fully
committed to sharing their
voices, insights and artistry to
audiences large
and small, grand and not so
grand, like those at the Library
of Congress and those at Boise
High School.
Poetry is an ancient art form
that continues to reinvent
itself and...
make itself newly-relevant,
generation after generation.
We are so proud to be here, to
introduce you today, to this
generation's finest young poets.
So... we have some wonderful
guests joining us here today.
Want to thank all of you.
It's my honor to welcome to the
podium, David Brooks.
[applause]
SPEAKER: I was talking to the
students, the poets, earlier,
and I mentioned when I was in
college, I replied to a short
story class, the professor
thought it was short story and
poetry, so, to get into the
class, we had to write a short
story and then also a poem.  And
I'd never written a poem before
in my life.  So I wrote the
story and wrote the poem and
wrote on the bottom...
"I make no claims on poetry" and
my professor wrote on the bottom
"and it makes no claims on you."
[laughter]
SPEAKER: So...
I, myself, do not have this
gift, but I'm the beneficiary of
poetry.
And I'm the beneficiary of the
written word and what I thought
I'd do, just for a few minutes
was try to illustrate what the
written word does for us.  So...
I have a home, ten blocks from
here, and I have a collection in
that home, and some people
collect stamps, I collect
accounts of different emotions.
And so... I collect accounts of
joy.
And so, for example, and when
you have all these accounts, you
realize it comes in layers.
There's physical joy that gets
-- when people are moving
together, my old history
professor, was named Louie
McNeill, he was in boot camp
marching with his memo and
experienced a moment of joy.
He wrote:  Words are inadequate
to express the emotion that's
involved.  A sense of pervasive
well-being is what I recall.
More specifically, a strange
sense of personal enlargement, a
swelling up, becoming bigger
than life, thanks to
participation in the collective
ritual.  So... that's one layer
of joy.
Another is what they call
collective effervescence.  Every
group of humanity dances in
rhythm when they're joyful.
So...
Zadie Smith was in London at a
nightclub when she heard Q tip
wrapping over the music and
describes this moment.  A rail
thin man with enormous eyes
reached across the sea of bodies
for my hand.  He kept asking me
the same thing over and over
"you feeling it?"  I was.  My
ridiculous heels were killing
me, I
was terrifies I might die, yet I
felt simultaneously overwhelmed
with delight that can I kick it
should happen to be playing at
this precise moment in the
history of the world and was now
morphing into smells like teen
spirit.
I took the man's hand, the top
of my
head flew away, we danced and
danced and gave ourselves up to
joy.
That's another layer.  Then
there's emotional joy.
One of my hero's in life is
Dorothy Day.  She got pregnant
and realized that most of the
accounts of childbirth she ever
read were written by men.  45
minutes after giving birth, she
wrote an account of her
beautiful
account and it ends with a
moment of joy.  She writes:  If
I'd written the greatest book,
composed the greatest
symphony or carved the greatest
figure, I wouldn't have exalted
the greatest
thing as I did when they placed
my child in my arms.  No human
could contain such a vast flood
of love and joy as I felt with
the birth of my young child and
with this came the need to
worship and adore.
When you see these moments,
you realize the joy happens when
the skin barrier between one
person and another disappears.
David White, a good poet writes:
Joy is a meeting place of deep
intentionality and self
forgiving.
The body can be what lies inside
us in communion with what
formerly seemed outside, but now
is neither.
Dance, laughter, affection, skin
touching skin, singing in the
car, music
in the kitchen, the quiet,
irreplaceable companion and
presence of a daughter.
The sheer intoxablity of a world
that was us and what was not us.
A couple higher levels.  One
is transcendent joy.  When we
think we're reaching across some
barrier that we can't really
explain.  So... I'm not a poet,
I have a friend who is an actual
poet.
His name is Christian Wyman.
Very beautiful poet.  When you
talk to Chris, he's lived in
a lot of cities, he always lived
there because there was a woman
there.
He lived in Buffalo, why
Buffalo?  Had a girlfriend
there.  Same with Rochester.
He lived in Prague, he had a
girlfriend there.
He was at the kitchen table and
a falcon landed on the window
sill across the window.  And it
scanned out and it didn't see
him, just was scanning like two
feet away from him and his
girlfriend was taking a shower,
so he went and got her and said
"come out, you have to see this.
"  She came out dripping naked
and they're standing there, just
with this
falcon right there and the
falcon turns and locks eyes with
Wyman.
And... his girlfriend said "wish
for something.
"  Take this moment, wish for
something
and he later wrote a poem about
the experience and includes this
stanza.
And for a long moment, I'm still
in, I wished and wished and
wished and wished and wished
that the moment wouldn't end and
just like that, it vanished.
So... that's that content
that people have with nature.
And then finally, the part
I'll end with and I don't have a
passage with
this, some moments of joy are
just transcendent, but moments
and then they go away, like
Wyman's, but for some people,
joy isn't an experience, it's an
outlook.  It's something they
bring into the world every day.
And it comes from the habitual
giving other people's delight.
It becomes a permanent way of
being in the world.  I was at a
luncheon here, a couple
years ago, I was seated next to
the Dalai Lama and the guy
laughed for no apparent reason.
He just starts laughing and you
want to be polite, so you laugh,
he laughs, you laugh and I had
nothing to say to
the guy, he was just so happy.
I finally said, he had a canvas
bag.  I said "you got any candy
in your bag."  He starts pulling
out the stuff in the bag.  It's
everything in the first class
cabin of an international
flight.  A little razor -- he
just radiates joy.
Kathy and I have a friend, Yo-Yo
Ma,
that guy just radiates joy.
That to me is a higher form of
life.  Why have I run through
all of this?  We're born with
relatively primitive
understandings of our own
emotions, at least men are.
[laughter]
SPEAKER: But what language --
and especially poetry does, it
educates us in our own emotions.
When you've read a poem, you
haven't gotten new knowledge or
new information, but you had a
new experience.  It's an
emotional experience and you
widen your repertoire of
emotions.
The greatest poet of our day,
Taylor Swift, was once asked --
[laughter]
SPEAKER: I sort of mean that.
They said you always wrote about
sadness.  She said, there's 23
different kinds of sadness.
She's an expert on sadness.
It's like we're born with one
piano key for joy, but through
poetry and through language, we
learn, there are actually 88
different piano keys and who
would want to live with a
simplistic notion of our
emotions when you can live with
an enriched one?  It makes life
so much better.  And then,
finally, if you realize joy is
the kind of thing that the Dalai
Lama or Yo-Yo Ma could
experience and project, why
would you want to live for just
mere happiness, when you could
have joy?  When you make that
kind of realization, a whole
life can turn around.
That's what I think you guys are
offering.
The explication of your own
emotions and giving everybody a
sense of what you learned about
them.
So...
i congratulate you, I thank you
for what you're about to do.
As I mentioned, on a serious
note, this is a moment when our
nation needs a
story and it needs to be told
through poetry.
I ask you spend time with us
next year filling a gap.  If
there's anything that's going to
unite such a diverse country,
it'll be poetry and story and
narrative.  And I'm sure you're
going play a role in that.
I've never experienced the kind
of joy that Sadie Smith did.  I
can't dance to Q tip.  But I
have had a couple experiences of
joy and this is a replication of
one of my earlier experiences.
Twice in my life I had this
experience.  Introducing Valerie
June.  This is my second and
this is joy personified.
Valerie?
[applause]
SPEAKER: Well...
I had the pleasure of spending
some personal time with the
students and...
I was asking each one of them
about their voices.  And... I'm
a musician, but... also a song
writer, and a poet as well,
so...
the voice of the poet is really
an interesting thing to me.
And one thing they told me, each
one in their different way of
how they hear the voice of a
poem, is, it usually starts with
one line.  And... I'll hear that
line and I'll live with
that line, again and again, for
a little
bit and then I'll start writing
the poem and the poems come
really fast once I hear that one
line and stick with it, then the
poem writing is fast after that.
So...
I hope that you go to your
regions and
you take those one lines and you
inspire everyone in your region.
I know you have this power, I
know you have the power to do
that.  It'll only take but one
line.  I'm going to play a song
for you on my little Bailey and
it's a song for love and for
healing.  And it's called
Somebody to Love.
Well if you're tired and
feeling so
lonely, you wake up at night and
you
think, only if you had somebody.
Well, I'll be somebody.
Somebody to love.
If it means there were plenty of
fish
in the sea, but you're out in
the cold and you're feeling
empty, all you're looking for is
somebody...
well, I'll be somebody.
Somebody to love.
Well, I'll be somebody, I'll be
somebody, I'll be somebody...
I'll be somebody, I'll be
somebody to love.
While you're watching the moon
rise in
the darkness of night and it's
unbroken because no it ain't
right, if you ain't got
nobody...
I'll be somebody.  Somebody to
love.
I'll be somebody, I'll be
somebody, I'll be somebody...
somebody,
I'll be somebody...
I'll be somebody
... I'll be somebody somebody to
love.
[applause]
SPEAKER: She's a sweet baby.
So... I'd like to invite the
poets to the stage now and Dr.
Matthews as well.
[applause]
SPEAKER: And representing the
Midwest
is Darius, and representing the
southeast is Daniel, and
representing
the northeast is Alexandra.
Representing the southwest is
Heather.  And representing the
west, Arianna Smith.
[applause]
SPEAKER: I believe they're each
going to read something.
SPEAKER: Thank you, all for
coming.  I'm the national
student poet representing the
Midwest.  I'm Darius.  I'm from
Huntington, West Virginia and
go to school at Interlock and
Arts Academy.
This is called beautiful day of
dance, for my father, widower at
33.
Mornings, when I woke up, my
face, sagging, defeated, dad
would smile at me and wave his
arms above his head, his legs
kicking beneath him.
A desperate flail, but a chance
to show he could move his body
as well as anyone.
When the sunlight seemed to
break and spill down his raised
chin like egg
whites and the chill bit into us
both, he's sing.  The song isn't
as important to me now as the
beauty of the dance and I'm sure
the melody was a repetitious
rip-off of
zip dido dah.  It's a beautiful
day to the blue that filled the
space behind the clouds, to
whoever was listening.
To the way I sweat at night, dad
rubbing the wet it
T-shirt that clung to my back
whispering it's okay.
Regretfully alive, but thankful
that we
could always spin ourselves
around, arms spread wide to live
and dance and to spinning
anyways, to sing always.
Thank you.
[applause]
SPEAKER: Shalom, y'all.
I'm Daniel Block and I'm the
southeast national student poet,
if you couldn't tell.
I'm from Birmingham, Alabama and
my comb is called 60.
Like his own father before him,
at 3:00 a.m.
, my father wakes, wanders the
house a
little, pours his cereal, no
eggs, no bacon, my father
doesn't touch meat.  Lifts
softly enough to enter and leave
the world a shadow, a breeze on
door steps.  He reads the news
until I wake.  On the way to
school, he'll talk about the
latest friend I didn't get to
meet.
This one was only 52 and lived
back in Harkoff.  They let
evening make meat of them.
My father shouts at the car
swerving in
its lane ahead of us and asks
"have you reconsidered being
vegetarian?
"  I say maybe, which we both
know means I don't want to go to
the trouble of saying no and we
pulled up to the school.  He
hasn't had a chance to talk
about the news or say how proud
he was to watch another morning
swell up through the cracks of
night.
I haven't had a chance to wish
him happy birthday and anyway,
what is there
to say but "good-bye my son" and
"good-bye my father who is my
son.
"  Whose eyes I carry into any
rear view mirror, any 3:00 a.m.
drive home when one car side
swipes another behind me.
My father who knows we live in
worlds of wheels.  All trying to
catch us.  Thank you.
[applause]
SPEAKER: Hello.  My name is
Alexandra.  I'm representing the
northeast.
I'm from Burlington, Vermont and
go to Burlington High School.
This is Puebla.  Puebla is
chocolate dipped, served me
as I spoon in out of the close
knit town surrounding Mexico
City.
I just want to gulp it down,
suck the
marrow from the cattle that get
leaner every year.
It smells good, being home or...
being in a place that was once
home.
I can't help but hold my breath,
obstructing my lungs because the
wind here is a different flavor
than the wind there.
I thought the thing I missed
most was the sizzle your bear
feet make against the packed
dirt of the evening road, but
I was wrong because I'm
intoxicated by
the way my grandma clasps her
hands to
my heart, like I never left.
Puebla tastes salty as I lick it
from my top lips, brushing it
from the corners of my eyes, let
it fall, absorb into my skin.
I know I can't come back until
the next thunderstorm season.
It gets easier to come and
harder to leave.
I wish I could stay in this town
where everything that tastes
like cayenne mixed with just the
right amount of lime.  It burns,
but... you laugh until the sour.
Thank you.
[applause]
SPEAKER: Howdy.
[laughter]
SPEAKER: I'm Heather from Mesa,
Arizona.
I'll be representing the
southwest.
This is
apologizing in hindsight.  I
hear July will bring the second
coming monsoon season and a
Stock Market crash, each light
on the water tower will blink
and then strobe.  A cougar will
sleep under my trampoline for
weeks.
Dogs will break into every
antique shop and devour fine
China.
From there, the moon will roll
across a cliff and crush the
nearest mobile home.
Today, they're dredging my best
friend's body from the lake.
She's wrapped in pink tarps and
identifiable by her ponytail.
Occasionally when I take a
shower, there's vomit already in
the bathtub.  I shouldn't be
here.  Not like this.  Three
weeks ago, we were kneeling at
the gulf of a psych ward with my
hands pressing a zip lock to her
nose and
mouth in lieu of a paper bag.
In hindsight, I'm not even an
effective attempt at a solution.
A threat is still a threat when
you pretend it's benign.  Sorrow
is still sorrow with my
headphones in.  Her grief was
still grief when I avoided it.
In the future, I still hope to
be unafraid of asking questions.
Her parents with join a nunnery,
the lake will drain through a
metal slit in the earth.
Her old things will appear on
every subway in the world.
In hindsight, I will look for
the
cliff crumbs in the cuffs of her
jeans.  In hindsight, I'll call
the hospital and tell them her
name.
[applause]
SPEAKER: My name is Arianna.
I'm from Las Vegas, Nevada.
I'll be representing the wedge
region.
This poem is entitled
Descendant.
Grandfather, burning crosses,
smoke clinging to black skin
like fresh cotton
to nimble fingers, breathing in
freedomless Zephyr.  Sunday
shoes stuck in rich wet moss.
Grandmother blooming out of rose
milkweed from the Carolinas,
twig-like
brown legs skipping across
sweeping willows,
pearl velvet swaying above her.
Father, product of Exodus from
south to north, the other side
of the sunshine.  My father, a
lingering love weaved from
ancestral needle and threat.
Blood line like a river, flowing
through state lines, Mississippi
currents of dripping peach wine.
I descend from the other side of
the
train tracks, resembling country
border
from
suction lips to buttery biscuits
on the kitchen stove.
Kaleidoscopes for eyes, freedom
writer's bus in a flame already
burning.
An eternity of southern
acrimony.  There lay heritage,
blood, spirit, bone.
Generations gone with the wind,
surviving through me, like DNA,
their
flesh dissolving like sugar
cube.  Some day we will all
taste liberation on the tips of
our tongues.
[applause]
SPEAKER: Well... I think we have
two poets from last year here.
Can you raise your hands?
Yeah... great.
Congratulations, thank you for
coming.  So...
I think we're going to have
reflections from Ann Castillo,
right?
And Ben is here to add
counterpoint, I'm sure.
[laughter]
SPEAKER: Hi, everyone, thanks
for having me back.  Welcome to
the appointment of this year's
national student poets.
I want to congratulate the class
of 2018.
Darius, Alex, Heather, Daniel,
and Arianna.
And to your parents, teachers,
friends, and supporters.  Thank
you for guiding these people who
write and envision change in
their community.
I wanted to offer a quick recap
of our year as the class of
2017.
Alongside Juliet, Kimsale, Ben
and Camila, I've had the best
year of my life.
For starters, I've made four
life-long friends.  Better yet,
we skipped school to travel
together to New York City in
October, the Aspen Ideas
Festival and Carnegie Hall in
June.  We were certainly the
recipients of a lot of
generosity.
People like Juan Felipe
lent us their time and wisdom
undeservedly.
Thanks to the hard work and
staff, we experienced
affirmation and received a
platform to share poetry with
our peers.  We were given the
space to write bravely and delve
deeply into poetry.
This year isn't about the
amazing gift each poet here has
been given, don't get me wrong,
we should say thank you often,
and sincerely.  This program is
the culmination of many people's
vision and hard work.
Virginia, Hannah, Debra, Olivia
and all the others who helped,
we thank you from the bottom of
our hearts.
In eighth grade, my English
teacher asked our class to write
essays, not
about the best gift we got over
winter break, but instead, about
the best gift we gave.  It
shifted our perspective to
generosity and thoughtfulness
and it was a lesson that stayed
with me.  I share this with you
because at its
heart, this is the magic of the
national poets program.  They
help us and we turn around to
help others.
I know the class of 2018 will
change their communities,
amplify the voices too often
left unheard.  Make more room at
the table for new and bright
poets.
I know this because each of you
is an astounding writer and
ambassador to your craft.  I
also know this because I've seen
the
same generosity in my friends.
Camila spent time helping teach
poetry therapy to immigrant
advocates and attorneys and
connected with refugees from
Somalia and the Congo.  Juliet
collaborated with doctors and
patients, using language to hear
emotional trauma in hospitals.
Kimsale spent time with native
students at the Sherman Indian
boardk school discussing
identity and the notion of home
and published a collection of
their writings.  Ben was poet
and residence for summer school,
giving academic enrichment to
local Minneapolis middle
schoolers.  They all
accomplished wonderful things, I
hope you'll take inspiration and
guidance from them as you search
for your own path forward.
Before we go, the class of 2017
wanted to give a few pieces of
advice.  Juliet says you should
learn from everyone you meet and
I agree.
Ben urges you to be unafraid, to
seize the opportunity you worked
so hard for.
We also recommend you wear
powder foundation in TV
interviews.  Send thank you
notes early.
Above all though, take a lesson
from Juan Felipe who spent the
last 15 minutes of our class
together showing us how to fold
Starbucks bags into makeshift
poetry booklets.
He was showing us how to make
room for poetry.
You're here because you earned
it.
We're standing beside you and we
can't wait to see what you'll
do.  Thank you.
[applause]
SPEAKER: Can we have another
round of applause, please?
[applause]
SPEAKER: I'm the program's
manager at the poetry and
literature center.  The task
falls on me to close out these
beautiful festivities.  Before I
do, I want to see if we can play
this video.  I'm told we may
have some luck.  Poetry keeps us
pliable, so... we'll try again.
[laughter]
[Music].
SPEAKER: I'm delighted to
congratulate you on having been
selected as this year's national
student poets.  It speaks to the
commitment that you've already
demonstrated to poetry as an art
form and as a way of life.
As I see it, poems teach us new
ways of looking at the world.
They give us new terms for
describing the many active and
powerful feelings that we live
with.  And they also allow us to
listen closely to other people's
voices and their stories.
I think all of that is
indispensable to a full life.
I'm thrilled that over the next
year, you will be able to go
into your community, doing this
with other people, talking about
why poetry matters to you.
That's what I've been doing over
the last year as poet laureate
and it's been one of the most
rewarding acts of my life as an
artist and a person.
To go into communities with
people I don't know, people I
may never see again
and feel like we actually have
something meaningful to say to
one another.  Through the
vehicle of poetry.  I'm sorry
I'm not there with you
tonight, I'm actually in Alaska,
talking poetry with new friends,
but I'm excited to join you
tomorrow and celebrate your
accomplishments.  [Music].
[applause]
SPEAKER: Thanks for your
patients, I'm glad you guys got
to hear her special words.
Before I close things out, I
want to
thank our partners for The
Alliance of
Poets and Writers and also
Valerie June.  Before I send you
off to celebrate, I want to
remind you that the National
Book Festival is this weekend
and student poets will be
performing at the festival twice
on the expo floor.  Come make
sure to check them out.  Also,
the full day is lots of fabulous
programming.
Make sure you check that out.
Very last thing there, are
surveys on your chairs.  It
helps us at the library.
That's all, please go out,
enjoy, congratulate our poets
and please have some food
outside.  Thanks, everyone.
[applause]
[Meeting concluded at 4:56 p.m.
ET].
in a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
"